welcome back to big mood we are here at
in our studios hey you know we're so
bougie that we each have individual
studios for the show pay $5,000 per
studio - you guys are just have no idea
how rich we are yeah and they're all in
private islands - my native fruit is
cherries - oranges - oranges mine is uh
dick bananas there you go whoa whoa this
are rare oh yeah we're by some thousand
dollars yeah they do is I try for it at
this place and it unknown expensive
bottles of tequila I know I'm selling
same one by the way I know I look like
an entire alcoholic but I'm on the same
same one we're all drinking we know
Nicky has coffee well okay thank you
here also for those of you listening at
home it's just us three today it's me
Nicky yeah you know oh [ __ ] yeah there's
no way to do this yeah there's no way to
do that maybe doesn't Dina we're missing
bows and tip today but you know what
we're gonna make up for it by being
extra and by extra I mean we're gonna
talk about all of the extra fights that
we've ever been part of within our
relationships
mostly toxic relationships I think yeah
my stories are all from like terrible
relationships these aren't things that
we're proud of but it's kind of like you
can look back and laugh we talked about
I'm part of these because I was always
right do you know Jesus Tina's fights
are legit yeah and she was litigated
probably yeah always right I liked about
this is I feel like this is another one
of those conversations in which the
podcast which was originally formed
where we talk about it in the group
chats and I've never gotten to talk
about this with anybody because I feel
like I don't want to sound crazy so we
just all avoid talking about it but
[ __ ] everybody's been through it
everybody has argued about something so
ridiculous and stupid got into screaming
fights about something [ __ ] dumb and
then now that you're grown you're like
oh I don't want to ever talk
always been mature so who wants to start
hmm I have one that I thought of it
happened not too long ago is when I was
still with Joe um and you know like I
like to think of myself as like the most
like pleasant person to be around delay
totally I've never I'm never hard to be
around like you can ask any one of my
friends like I'm the easiest person to
be around like nine percent so jess is
really bubbly supervisor positive hi
mystic so clearly earring so clearly
he's wrong okay let's write write this
he's that
so we were we were trying to find
something to eat and I'm like the type
of person who if I get hungry I don't
realize it until it's too late
and I'm hangry and I think a lot of
people that happen to them too but for
me so this one day we were like oh I'm
I'm hungry and he was like okay let's go
find something to eat he's like what do
you want to eat I'm like I don't know
and he goes what about this chicken spot
so I'm like okay we'll go to this
chicken spot so we drive from downtown
LA all the way to like I don't know it
was far like Compton or something it was
like it was a drive it was enough of the
drive tour by the time I got there I was
even more hangry so we get into the
restaurant and she's like oh it's gonna
be about a 40-minute wait and so I'm
like
oh my okay so the hangry is just boiling
over at this point we sit down at the
table and I'm just like that a tooth
kind of starts you know and I'm just
kind of like fidgeting and then the
waitress is like can I get you something
to drink and I'm like a [ __ ] Dr
Pepper I guess you know like I'm being a
total [ __ ] right yes oh yeah I mean
like that's obviously normal behavior
and though yeah she could kind of share
in the face but she didn't so obviously
she's like I didn't throw at her when
she told me 40 minutes all right calmly
sat down and so like he's noticing like
my energy just being so bad so he's like
do you wanted to try something else and
I'm like yeah let's just try something
else I cannot wait 40 minutes and then I
noticed that there was like a KFC across
the street sound like hey cool we still
get chicken and but we can eat it much
faster so we walk across the street it's
literally like KFC is across the street
from an actual restaurant and then we're
in the car and we're about to get out
and Oh cuz we had to move the car just a
little bit but we're in the car and then
so I can't remember what started the
fight but he started [ __ ] getting so
crazy I mean I keep like I definitely
pushed his limits and he started [ __ ]
freaking out like hitting the [ __ ]
steering wheel and he was like you're
being such a [ __ ] [ __ ] like I get
your hanger but you're being such a
[ __ ] and I go well [ __ ] yeah you know
and it's like get out of the car and he
[ __ ] left and he left me there and
that was the most ridiculous fight I
think that I can remember in the in the
recent history because I basically was
hangry and was being a [ __ ] and I got
left at KFC in Compton did you even
thought he left you there I never ate
the chicken when you said he left I
thought he walked away like no you have
a car oh he drove off you know I started
it maybe I deserved it I don't think I
did but I kind of probably did because I
haven't I'm a really big [ __ ] where I
want to be but yeah so I got left at a
KFC parking lot
in the back he didn't over home do Jess
all of my stories make me look really
bad yours is like you know more like
excel you know I told you I'm right and
every single argument so I don't have
any I don't have any crazy I've
abandoned people inside the world like
twice one time was this guy that I was
seeing and he threatened to hit me so I
left him in the middle of oh yeah I left
him in the middle of a road trip and
then like he didn't have gas money or
anything to get home
he was a crying about ace I can't money
I guess when you get home I was like
that sounds like a personal problem
[ __ ] bye and then I booked myself like
a hotel room and then like I booked
myself like a flight home the next day
like I'm go [ __ ] are you getting home
what happened no no because we went on a
road trip to new Mara and then like on
the way home he was being like a little
[ __ ] about something like oh you don't
want to visit my family in my hometown
okay I'll just like hang out with my
ex-girlfriend or something I'm just like
don't do that like don't [ __ ] me and
then he's like so he's like okay you
don't want to visit my family so I'm
gonna hang with my ex-girlfriend and I'm
gonna hit you in the face so and that
and then I was like no you can't do that
and he goes why not I'm like Hello
because that's your ex-girlfriend so
he's like well you're being a [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] right now I'm like because I
won't let you hang out with your
ex-girlfriend and then his eyes I can
you not call me that like that's really
mean your ex-girlfriend was crazy she
stabbed you hello like I don't want my
boyfriend to hang out with this ex
what's so crazy about that he goes if
you keep talking I'm gonna [ __ ] hit
you so I took off my seatbelt I got in
his face while he was driving and I was
like oh [ __ ] could you just say to me
say it again say it again and then so
with honestly this huge argument of
course he didn't it again he knew that
he would die I'll [ __ ] grab that wheel
all crashes both [ __ ]
sounds like pullover and then I booked
myself a hotel room and he tried to
follow me and stay in the hotel room and
then like the front desk I was like oh
how many keys do you need I'm like just
one and then he's like oh no she's just
kidding we need two keys and I looked at
the front desk I was like I don't know
who this is
can you not like give him a key oh gosh
so like he followed me to my room he was
crying and I did like I looked at him I
was like whiny little [ __ ] dude like
you don't threaten to hit me yeah yeah I
mean like hello and then so he wouldn't
leave so I like grabbed his keys and I
threw it over the balcony I'm like go
fetch [ __ ] and then like he had to go
on like his keys and then I booked
myself a flight home the next day and I
don't know what happened after that
and then so like I don't know how I got
home but later on he called me and then
he was like go kill yourself do you not
understand
[Laughter]
no like I have no sympathy for anyone
who threatens or hits their you know
significant others or anything so the
last time I spoke to him I was like
which part of go kill yourself even
understand them he looked finally left
me alone after two years of like
harassing me Wow and then the second
time was when this guy I was seeing like
we got fast food music drunk and then
like he threw his fast food at me like
it hit the door it didn't hit me but hit
the door I was driving and I was like
get the [ __ ] out of the car right now
and left him at a Carl's jr. in the
middle of night at like got the
treatment that I [ __ ] like fit and
then I got left out of burped out of
[ __ ] KFC even though I was kind of
being a [ __ ] sort of cuz like I was
sober and he was drunk and then I like
gave him the spoon also dude just shut
the [ __ ] up and eat your food yes I was
kind of mean about it so afterwards we
talked about it and I was like okay he's
looking sorry I threw stuff at you I'm
like I'm sorry I was a [ __ ] at you I
think it's funny because people are
probably like oh these are gonna be cute
funny arguments like over the toilet
seat and then we just start
and whistling like really toxic yeah
yeah me that's me thinking about you
guys yeah okay I have ones that made me
look psycho and they're just like over
something stupid like toothpaste yeah I
would like memory recall so I'm like
okay this stood out to me because it was
like emotionally damaging so like maybe
if you say some more things helping us
alright well I mean okay I'll start
light you know in one where I felt like
I feel like both parties are kind of
understood here in this argument this
was like the first year that Steve and I
lived together and I was [ __ ] poor
okay like I had and so I had this set of
pots like nonstick pots that had been my
only set of pots
my only cookware that I've had since I
moved to LA so I'd had it for like five
years and and I moved in with Steve and
Steve started using my pans and pots and
that's fine like I like whatever but he
cuts the chicken no the pan but oh I
know I know and so okay the first time
he did it I was like don't cut your
chicken in the non-stick pan you're not
supposed to cut on the non-stick and
then he got into this whole debate and
argument with me about how that's
[ __ ] and how it doesn't actually
poison you and how like it doesn't
poison the food and it's totally fine he
doesn't I know I know and then like it
makes it not nonstick anymore yeah so
I'm like okay we'll do it in your own
pants and don't do it in my pants well
he would sometimes confuse his pants for
my pants and he would continue to do
this and he did it like so many times
and then we every time I wasn't allowed
to like argue with him because he would
just use the argument about it not being
dangerous and I'm like that's not the
point the point is that it's my pan and
you're ruining it so this goodbye this
[ __ ] his own new pan and I was
like here's a new pan for you here's a
new pan for me don't [ __ ] touch his
pan it's a whole different color than
the rest of the pans it's white like
don't touch it and
my mind and I lost I just started like
it just boiled to the point where I'm
like how do I stay strong and ass
[ __ ] argument because I know that
this is this is something worth like
drawing the line for but also it's a
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] pans and pots and
his whole thing was like one it doesn't
it's not toxic but also he hated that
his ex-girlfriend also got mad at him
for cutting chicken in her pants and so
it like triggered he's like me be like
his ex-girlfriend or something I'm like
you know what a broken clock is Right
twice a day you know I don't like her
either - Nikki I remember being in the
car I think in Vegas and the whole thing
about the [ __ ] cutting the lemons on
the counter came up and Steve and I kind
of took Steve's side on that one because
I was like I kept lemons on the counter
- like I'll cut it on a paper towel and
if the paper towels not cut then I know
I didn't cut the counter and then Mickey
was sitting there going hmm
come around I have come around to his
argument see I'm very fair I if I'm you
know like if I gurus find out a new
information I'll I'll be fair about it
but speaking of cutting things on the
counter you wouldn't need to cut any
food on the counter if you were getting
your meals from daily harvest which I'm
freakin that love I love daily harvest I
even so they sponsored the show
obviously their sponsor about to talk
about them and they sent us each
shipment to like test out the daily
harvest meals and I liked it so much
that I have to live or derd two more
rounds of it because they're just so
easy they're so convenient they're super
healthy I feel like it gives me enough
energy through the day they deliver
clean food right to your door all their
food is built on fruits and vegetables
there's no preservatives no added sugar
and artificial ingredients it takes just
a few minutes to prepare and I never
have to question if what I'm eating is
healthy you see everything stays fresh
in the freezer until you're ready to
enjoy it you don't have to overthink you
don't have to cook you just put it in
the microwave and it's like it takes
three minutes and it's amazing and it's
fresh and it's good and delicious and
daily harvest works directly with farms
so they freeze organic fruits and
vegetables at peak ripeness to lock in
the nutrients and taste right now I'm
actually eating the lentil Bowl is like
the
tomato bowl and it's freaking delicious
it's call like a Bolognese but it's all
vegetables
anyway daily harvest is also committed
to minimizing their environmental impact
they're in the process of transitioning
to 100% compostable recyclable packaging
and are over 50% of the way there
already so go to daily harvest comm and
enter the promo code big mood to get my
$25 off your first bucks that's that's
huge promo code big mood for $25 off
your first box at daily harvest comm
daily harvest con that's such a good
discount that I ordered again on with
using our coach yeah and if you're way
too lazy with sack potatoes like me and
you don't even like we have door - yay I
love food absolutely to me because I'm
gonna do anything especially a lazy ox
just sit around play video games all day
and you don't want to move you don't
hear anything now in this quarantine
you've counted on restaurants and now
they're counting on you and while their
dining rooms may be closed they still
opened or this will open for delivery on
door - which is what I've been using
because I like to support my local
restaurants because I know that it's
very hard for them right now door - is
the app that brings food to you to your
door whatever that you're craving
there's over 300 thousand partners in us
with Oneko Canada and strea and you can
support your local go twos or choose
from your favorite national restaurants
like Chipotle Wendy's and the turkey
burgers many of your favorite
restaurants are still open for delivery
please support them so that when
everything is blown over they'll still
be open
just open the door - app select your
favorite local restaurant and your food
will be left at your door you don't even
got to talk to people or touch them they
will leave it at your door right now our
listeners can get five dollars off their
first order of $15 or more and zero
delivery fees for their first month when
you download the door -
half and enter the code big mood that's
five dollars off her first order and
zero delivery fees for a month when you
download the door - app in the App Store
and enter the code big mood don't forget
that's the code big mood for five
dollars off your first order with door -
so don't just download the app put in
our code to you know pigment so about
the lemons Jess I put them sometimes on
paper towel on the counter but I think
at that time I was so paranoid about
ruining our countertops because we had
just moved into our new house and we
before then we had tile and it was in an
apartment and it was like cheapest [ __ ]
and I was like cut all you want on a
counter but then when we moved into like
a nice kitchen I was like I don't want
to ruin it I've never had like a nice
countertop before and then I saw it
I also saw like certain parts of granite
countertops get burned by the acid in
citruses so yeah yeah it edges out yeah
you can think of this special polish it
actually happened on our kitchen island
that I bought separately from our
kitchen like it didn't come with the
kitchen but yeah I had that has a
granite countertop and the limes have
definitely ruined the countertop I've
never seen limes ruin a countertop
that's why I was like I kind of took
Steve's side I was like oh no I think
it's fine yeah I get it for the cutting
part but like you have an actual acid
from okay I didn't know that was like
that but I do I will say that since then
I have watched Tim cut on our countertop
and it doesn't has not damaged anything
so I'm okay with it okay I had a kitchen
argument to like you know those um those
drying racks for your dishes yeah and
there's like a tray underneath that
connects collects the water and it
Lincoln's okay so he would argue is like
that's mold I'm like that's calcium
because it's white its water why would
there be mold ripping from clean dishes
in a clean dish rack like it doesn't
make sense to me and we gots like this
huge argument about it which like while
we were arguing I was like this is so
dumb like why are we fighting over this
but it's like one of those things where
we both have to be right and I'm like
eventually I was like you know what if
it makes you
comfortable I'm just gonna buy a new
dish wait why can't you just clean it
with bleach or whatever that's like it's
like it's a it was like one the old ones
that came with a house so just to
eliminate altogether
yeah one of those like distress that
hangs over the sink so everything just
drips the water down yeah oh yeah I have
that yeah you know yeah but it was like
one of those arguments room like this is
so [ __ ] stupid but I want to be right
and he was the same way too and then we
both like that he was like super OCD
about like stuff in the kitchen whatever
like super crazy about it so I mean at
least we learned something about each
other after that site I suppose I think
thing too is that like I I'm pretty
stubborn and I always pick stubborn
partners so yeah do put fights happen
that way you see ourself up for this
[ __ ] guys it's true it's true but then
at the same time I can't date anyone
who's a pushover because yeah eventually
I lose respect for them I'm like God is
like stand up for yourself do not just
steamroll them you know so I need
someone that can like all right long you
can hold your ground like it keeps me
check too you know yeah I just get bored
if someone's always agreeing with me
even if it's like because I feel like it
was it's not just arguments but it's
also like perspectives on things like if
we're watching a movie like I want
someone on a date with this guy and I
liked him when I met him but then we
went on a date and we watched a movie
and he asked me how what I thought of
the movie and I went into detail about
different parts that I liked and like
why I liked them and and what parts I
didn't like and why I didn't like them
and all the like thorough analysis of
this movie and then I'm like what did
you think and he goes yeah I pretty much
felt the same way I never saw that guy
good you need to have your own thoughts
oh yeah I could not like if you and cuz
it happened more than once it wasn't
that just that one movie it was like
opinions on anything he would just agree
with me full-on like no differing
opinions no like added to that opinion
so you're just not showing personality
basically I was just like trying to be
whatever you like want him yeah yeah I
mean do you think we like drama or do
you think we just I mean what is
I think it's stimulating conversation in
my opinion I think like I really enjoy
actually when Steve has a perspective
that I don't have or didn't see before
because he's actually done a really good
job at swaying me to his side in many
different arguments or times that we had
differing opinions and some of them I
thought I had a really hard stance on
but then he swayed me over so you know
he's really good yeah I mean we're both
stubborn but also we're open to
listening to ya the arguments from the
other side and that's what I like is
like that's yours you won't listen to
the argument or like won't listen to
your side at all like they cannot be
swayed then that sucks but also if they
just always agree with you that sucks -
yeah but yeah I am I like I like it
because they are strong enough to have
their own opinions and defend their own
opinions and they'll just go and not
just go with everyone but I I love when
someone is open to you know to a
different opinion but also knows when
they're wrong - I remember there was guy
that I was seeing and we got into like
this huge argument and he and I are
extremely like hard-headed extremely
stubborn and then like we were arguing
over something and then like I made a
really good point
and then I listened he went quiet he
goes you know what you're right and I'm
sorry I was wrong and I was I was like
damn dude the amount of [ __ ] victory
that that feels like if you're in the
middle of a heated art you know someone
goes just stops it and goes you know
what you're right it go yeah you're like
but the thing is like I didn't even
would that happen I didn't even think
like [ __ ] yeah I won the first thing
that came to my mind was oh my god that
was really mature and I'd like to see so
much more now yeah but still that
victory though like I'm winning that
[ __ ] argument it feels really [ __ ]
good yeah it does yeah so like it was
this was like early on in like the
dating and at that point like when that
happened I was like oh okay you know
what I can really see myself being with
this guy because he is strong enough to
admit like oh hey I was wrong and you
were right you know
yeah like I agent I just like completely
respected him way more like if I was
thinking I was gonna [ __ ] bang this
dude and leave now it's just like
I might bang the student stay for a
little bit are they staying him a second
time right at least being in the second
time yeah well I feel I feel like I'm I
don't really get into like arguments
with boyfriends about small things like
the toilet seat or something in the
kitchen or you know like like putting
your clothes this way or that way but I
mean there was a couple times where I
was like annoyed because I was doing
laundry for my ex and like he would
always leave his socks like kind of
[ __ ] up and like hmm you know like all
together and I would be like can you
just at least put your socks out or you
know I don't know something like that
but I think mostly because I grew up
with my dad I'm used to a man like not
really considering like the little
details that like we like to kind of
fuss over a little bit so I just kind of
do everything myself what I have noticed
though is I'll get into stupid arguments
with girlfriends lately with girls I get
it like one of my best best friends from
when I was living in Texas we got into
this huge [ __ ] fight over like a
parking space at her apartment complex
like she like I was gonna come see her
like I looked like in the town over so
like I needed to come see her and like I
needed a park in her parking spot or
something but she was like oh can you
just use the parking spot that's like
way on the other side of the complex and
then just walk over cuz it's just much
easier for me or whatever blah blah blah
and we were just fighting over this
[ __ ] parking spot and I was like dude
like just let me use the parking spot in
front of your door because like I'm the
guest it's convenient for me and like I
was being a total [ __ ] [ __ ] about
this parking spot I swear to god we
didn't talk probably three weeks after
that I don't know why like I felt like I
had to push so hard on this [ __ ]
parking spot thing but I pushed so hard
and I like I don't feel like I pushed
guys that hard over miniscule things but
with my girlfriends I have and like it's
so weird like I don't understand ever
gotten into like big arguments with my
girlfriends before yeah yeah I feel like
I'm the opposite yeah I almost like bend
over backwards for my girlfriends but
for the guys I think because I like
Ethan's been too long since we've had
sex or something like where there's like
sexual tension I'll just find ways to
like ticket them yeah but yeah all my
girlfriends have always been like
like I first of all I didn't have a lot
of friends growing up in general but
well the friends I did have they were
all like all of us had brothers so no
one was really like no one was really
caddy or like they weren't like sister
people like we didn't have like that
typical group of girlfriends that yeah
like you get together and you gossip and
you talk about you know nails and boys
and stuff like they were just like more
chill and into video games and comedy
and yeah just like you know what I think
it is I think it's that I expect more
from females I'm like you have the same
mind that I have guys on the other hand
are dumb as [ __ ] yeah my graphic tations
of them are so much higher and I'm like
if we're not on the same page like how
the [ __ ] is this happening how do you
not understand you know that I'm your
guest and you need to give me the
parking spot in the front I would never
knew you know like true that's a little
crazy little crazy part of me one of the
craziest [ __ ] that's ever happened to me
was I started dating this guy have you
guys ever been called by their
ex-girlfriends name before no we did one
time I did but not during sex no olena
we got 36 days I don't have a body in my
backyard right now right I could be
there I can help you yeah thank you
so dude this one time so we went on a
trip with like his friends and
everything right we were all getting
ready to go out that night and like he
was like taking pictures with his
friends let's say her name is Amy okay
so you sing a picture with his friend
luck Amy Amy converts you can picture
with us and I was just like and then all
the his friends looked at him like he
could hear a pin drop drop dudes and he
didn't even notice he didn't realize it
and then like all his friends looked at
me like oh [ __ ] and then what if it like
you see
I saw one of his friends is leaning and
whispering him to him like just she just
called her
Amy and I he's looked at me he turned
and he looked at me he's like oh [ __ ] I
went to the bathroom
and I was [ __ ] yelling at him were
you laying in the bathroom I change
smoked a whole pack of cigarettes that
was Gena and this was after quitting
smoking oh yeah
so like he like we made up cuz like they
dated for [ __ ] years for like five
years right me that's got me and this
guy just stated for like a few months
all right
so I was like I was furious but then
like so when I'm angry I had to call
people and like hey am i right for being
angry and I need you to be honest with
me right so I called my mom I was like
mom I need you like this is what
happened this is whatever and she is one
who talked me down she's like listen
they were together for a long time like
you guys just barely started dating and
like look at me I have kids and I still
get you guys names mixed up every once
in a while you know and I was like okay
fine I'll let it slide two weeks later
dead dizzy dead no there's another group
of friends and they were like bro what
the [ __ ] like it was like his friends
were ash like dude [ __ ] 1zz have I
know right and then so like we can to
another argument whatever right he's
like I'm sorry like when I was dating
her like I didn't really it was one of
those like relationships where it's like
he told her from the beginning like I
don't think I'm ever gonna marry you and
she spent the whole relationship trying
to change him I know what [ __ ] Jeana was
they were like young they're really
super young so he was like I never
called her babe I never called her like
um like nicknames like I call you I just
called her by her name Amy all the time
but with you I just leave if I tell you
this whatever you know so I'm not used
to it like when referring to you in like
third person or whatever great first
person yeah all right and then so like
we get over that and then it happens a
third time
like two weeks later bro and I noticed
this only happens when he's drinking so
we were at a we're at a party and like
her kind of like yeah she gave me to
these Vietnamese too huh yeah she's nice
to you and then so this happens again
we're at a party
oh hi puppy so we're at a party and
puppy so this time we're at a party and
then he's and he's talking to his friend
like oh yeah yeah let's drink um Amy can
take a shot with us and I just looked at
him and this is awesome and this guy was
there during the first time it happened
too and I already knew and he looked at
me and I look at him cuz he was one of
the guys that comforted me afterwards
like after it happened like he fooled me
as a Yale listen like this happens all
the time so sorry having you the first
time it happened so when I happened to
get he just look at me and I'm just like
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] lose my [ __ ] and
then so he leans in he goes well you
just called her Amy and then like my
dude just like just and I'm just like
like staring daggers bro like staring
[ __ ] daggers so I go to the bathroom
we're like arguing in the bathroom he's
like I'm so sorry I don't know why this
happens they only happens when they
drink listen a man won't do it again the
apology he called me by her name again
oh my god language I don't know how he
made it out of that house alive like I
wanted to crawl his [ __ ] eyes out
right so during during the [ __ ]
apology like I'm so sorry ain't I won't
do it again
[Laughter]
just came out with a knife in audio
she's got her dogs - my dogs so during
like the initial argument when it first
like when it happened I was like trying
to keep it down so I don't like making
scene I never argue in public I don't
like letting people know that we have
like issues within our relationship I
never make a scene but the moment when
he was he called me that during the
argument well I like open the door I did
a lap around the bedroom I slammed the
door shut and I screamed oh you shut the
window say Shh like stop screaming I was
like okay stop screaming it's like
savior embarrass me you just called me
my ex-girlfriends name again
while apologizing to me dude I was so
easy missing brain cells men are [ __ ]
stupid men are it's like a sitcom yeah
like yeah right so I was like I'm
[ __ ] going home dude like I left the
party his brother was there and he knew
what happened he's like and he said you
know don't you know don't be this way
like don't just like just say I'm like
no dude like I am he's something you
don't be this way
no not don't be this way but like hey
you know just like don't don't don't let
this get to you I'm so sorry like I know
he's [ __ ] stupid his brother was
actually really sweet his brother was
like Amy don't don't be this way I'll
kill the whole family dude the whole
family would die so and then so his way
making up for it was like later on he
was like so we're not because I'm so
sorry look I I need to call you by your
name Morris I'm used to your name you
know and then so like for Lacey say Gina
all the time like the next few weeks is
like I miss you Gina
is there anything that you want Gina
like overemphasize it is overemphasizing
names these men yeah
crane ugly memory in there yeah but when
he's drinking he can go on autopilot
yeah and I call my mom and I told her it
happened again
she was like and and then like she's
like you do realize that he ever meets
us and he called you that when we need
him we're gonna bury him in our backyard
right yeah we're fine like we have like
a large plot of land we can do it dude
I've never I'm just really happy it
didn't happen during sex is it what
happened during sex you would see me in
the [ __ ] 8 o'clock news running from
the cops covered in blood dude I just
hope that he doesn't ever say anyone's
name ever during sex because he can't
handle that amount of pressure
exactly right like if I were him I would
say like if we were to ever get married
and we're at the altar he better [ __ ]
review my name at least 6 times before
he says Gina I do because if this [ __ ]
happens at the altar y'all it's gonna
turn into the [ __ ] Thunderdome in
there and you guys are all gonna see it
unfold and just imagine you guys having
sex though and him being like do you
like that gene map suck my D no Gina
Gina oh my god you guys ok enough about
that we need to take a really quick ad
break and I'm gonna tell you guys about
a sponsor that I absolutely love and
this is a girl that's your because if I
were to get into a fight during my
wedding this app is gonna make me hella
strong why okay so you guys when the
quarantine started I was being a
complete and total POS I stopped eating
healthy I stopped working out I could
feel myself deteriorating and finally
like last week I was like okay I feel
like crap the quarantine is gonna lift
at some point I don't want to be a
complete just slob and blob and hate
myself by the time it's over so I yeah
like I had a personal trainer before but
now he's not available we have to social
distance can't see him so I've been
using Numa and numa's hopes
I my diet is the worst part so like I am
I'm kind of okay with working out like I
can get a little bit motivated for that
but when it comes to the calories that
I'm eating that's a really hard thing
for me to let go of like I love eating
candy and all this stuff and it's like
not so good for you so this apps really
helpful in some sort of psychological
things that you're dealing with too like
why are you eating so much [ __ ] candy
like can you stop you know that kind of
thing so this app helps you to feel good
about your choices and improve your
sense of self-worth I've actually I mean
there's a lot more things to this app
than that but I personally have lost
three pounds in seven days Wow oh [ __ ]
flecks on ice yeah it's super easy it
works with your lifestyle
it's basically psychology they teach you
why you do the things you do and it
empowers you with the tools to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
it's based on a cognitive behavioral
approach and it uses personalized
courses to help you reach your specific
goals and it only takes like a few
minutes a day to log into the app and
kind of get yourself going you're
assigned a goals specialist and matched
up with a community of numerous so
there's always support and people going
through the same thing as you are there
is a science to getting healthier and
it's called new sign up for your child
today at noon that's in oom calm /big
mood what do you have to lose honestly
just give it a try I know you're sitting
on the couch I know you're sitting on
the couch doing nothing and eating
Cheetos so give it a drive in town six
legs again visit Newcombe slash a big
mood to start your trial today that's
Noom in oom dot-com / big mood and along
with being healthy and working out you
also have to take care of your insides
baby mm-hmm
we have Kara which is a vitamin and
supplement subscription it's a wellness
brand that makes it easy to maintain
your health goals the customized vitamin
plan that helps
do your best today and support you
long-term and I like it because well
okay so I have like a lizard brain like
a little monkey brain that's very cute
things you know what you do is you go on
their website you take this really cute
quiz
that it's like a it's a quiz to ask you
like hey what do you want to focus on
like what's shitty about your body what
do you want to fix your eggs and then
like you get to choose so many things
like I chose I want to fix my sleep
habits my energy levels and like my
internal guts and then they make like a
customized packet of vitamins for you
it's basically has two free vitamins and
supplements delivered to your house it
makes it super easy to support your
health goals the packs are like little
convenient daily packs that you can rip
open and just take your vitamins but
also what's really cool about it it's
it's biodegradable biodegradable and
it's made of compostable films and
there's tons of info on how to compost
them in or on the care of website so
it's like all of this is really cool it
comes in a little box you can pull it
out like everyday and just take your
vitamins and it makes me feel like I'm
doing something to help myself I don't
really do anything else so for 50% off
your first care of order go to take
Harold's calm and enter the code big
move 54 fifty percent off your first
order again go to take care of calm and
enter the code big mood 50 oh but also
I'm gonna add to it
Oscar Pierre they also have powders that
gives you energy and it's good for your
tummy and the cool thing is you get to
also choose like do you want to try like
um like crazy like Western other you
know like natural ingredients for ganda
and all these other things yeah yeah I
can't pronounce yeah I kind of want to
try that and they go so many things you
can see care of I actually really like
it I'm gonna order more ah yeah
alright because I want your help
insights so you can buy your insights
taken care of I put on my bag I'm gonna
take all the vitamin DS laughs this
quarantine I'm gonna get somebody I know
I want my body to be [ __ ] sculpted
cuz girl I'm gonna be
[ __ ] after the shits over your rabbit
you guys won't hear from me for a while
like I'm gonna be out of so many
episodes because I'm gonna be just
getting dick if you like look where the
dick is cuz that's always like we're
missing Jess today because you loads of
dick now girls get into shape now you
just can't just can't film the podcast
miles you know I learned a while back
when I was like reading articles on like
relationships and stuff and one of the
things that I learned was if you're like
getting into an argument with your
significant other or like you're
starting to get annoyed or you guys are
starting to get to a point where you
guys gonna argue um check yourself and
ask yourself am i hungry or am I tired
and if it's and if you say yes any of
those then that might be the reason why
you guys are picking a fighter right now
oh yeah a lot of times it could be like
you you're insecure about something or
you need something and you're like
putting too much on them too I remember
one I got mad at the sky one time like
that super mad like I didn't start a
real fight but I noticed like in my body
I was upset and it didn't create that
much of a problem but I I was like why
might have said about this like he was
like I came to see him and he was tired
and he fell asleep kind of early like at
11 p.m. and I remember sitting there
being like what the [ __ ] you're supposed
to be hanging out with me like now yeah
you know and I was like wait why would I
be upset about that like he's tired yes
sleep like that's not the last time
seems like so I think sometimes too when
people fight it's kind of like they just
they're needing something and they're
not looking to themselves like why
why would I be mad at someone else for
that that's something I need a handle
yeah you know or like when I got hungry
and I was hangry and I was with Joe it's
like that's my fault that I'm here
that's not Joe's fault like why does he
have to deal with my wrath yeah and I
should have taken care of that myself so
sometimes I like when I get mad nowadays
like these days I'm like okay where's
this coming from
it's probably not their fault at all
what is it yeah you know Steve and I
actually realized that we both do that
when we haven't had sex in a while like
if it's been more than a week or a week
and a half is like kind of the point
where both of us kind of get like at
each other yeah and like once we bacon
out it's all great but we don't even
realize it's that because we're not
horny in that moment when we're like
getting like alright added each other
but it's because like we just haven't
made time to be intimate or like feel
connected and so we're actually both of
our love languages is quality time so
we're actually like craving that quality
time I just picture you and Steve
fighting like this it turns into [ __ ]
you two are so cute that the way I
imagine you guys arguing like you let
liquor that's like that would happen to
me too like why like sometimes I just
sit there and I'm just like I want to be
a [ __ ] why aren't I being such a [ __ ]
right now Lee and I know it seems like I
know I'm being a [ __ ] right now but
I've gotten too far to get bad PMS no
would I PMS I'm not like I don't get
angry I get really needy like I want my
attention if I don't I'm gonna get like
really pouty I don't I don't turn this
well [ __ ] you know oh that's the only
that's the time where I turn into a
[ __ ] and I'll even call it out like
I'll feel it off of something that's not
even it's nothing it's like yeah I used
a little
last cake up for the Keurig or whatever
and I really wanted a second cup of
coffee and I [ __ ] useless and it's
just like this normally I could just be
like oh that sucks you know I'll get it
tomorrow or whatever but because of PMS
I don't know what it is but the my
hormones [ __ ] rage in there and yo my
blood boiling and it just gets so men
and if sleep so much is like blinks
wrong I'll be like I mean that's and
that's hormones too so it makes sense
cuz it's your hormones [ __ ] with your
brain and I'm even self-aware like my
logic - like this is a logical to get
mad at or have emotions about so I'll
even call it out as I mad I'll be like I
know it's a rational for me to be really
mad right now but I am yelling because I
can't control my volume because I'm so
mad I'm so frustrated just don't talk to
me for your own safety you're just like
even when you're mad you're so cute as
[ __ ] it's like not even scary and I
wouldn't tell them that they get even
angrier the other day because it started
my period and I didn't understand why
was that a whole day I was feeling like
I was needy
I felt ugly and like it's also
quarantine I wanted attention and like I
was on stream like guys I'm having a bad
day they're like why and I'm like and I
didn't understand why I'm like I knew my
period was coming but it usually doesn't
happen like this so it was like really
weird for me and then like like and then
like two days later it actually like my
period came and I was like alright yeah
see I told you yeah start getting mad
that I'm getting mad like logic so funny
enough and then I get sad that I got mad
at me ya know that it's so funny he
thinks if I were to bring it up like are
you on your period or something I'll be
like shut up [ __ ] up don't you ever
[ __ ] ask me that yeah
don't you know what I mean like it's so
funny because yes I am but don't [ __ ]
ask me that Oh calm down bro
or like you're overreacting [ __ ] do you
want to see me overreact because I'll
show you that's my favorite you want to
see me mad dude go ahead oh good oh I
was just it made me think of the fights
I used to get in with my ex-boyfriend
like two x's ago but but the first
boyfriend ever lived with and it was the
opposite sort of thing that you were
talking about Jess you know how you were
talking about how girls see all these
little details but guys are dumb they
don't see it I never saw it before I was
always like the messiest person in our
household I was just a slob like I used
to have a pathway that went to my head
because I just haven't is that thank you
to save it's okay though right
preferences house is [ __ ] immaculate
I know and TIFF to TIFF is so neat so
anyway this boyfriend was a neat freak
like a total Virgo total neat freak like
like just minimalist neat freak would
every like once a week would take all
the items out of the bedroom and wash
them one by one and then put them back
into the bedroom really I feel like he
didn't have a he didn't feel like he had
a purpose and so that gave him purpose
but anyway that's fitting it's a control
they had to clean because that like
that's how they control their lives
gives them some sort of control today
I'm gonna [ __ ] make sure everything
in my [ __ ] house is immaculate Carol
ate really but I did learn how to clean
from living with this dude because he he
was so detailed and he would clean the
entire house he even had a bucket that
had all these different types of
cleaners in it cuz it was like one for
each type of surface and you had
different types of paper towels it was
those [ __ ] nuts dude okay when the
track of it same and I have a
multi-purpose cleaner but that's as far
as I get but so one day
he cleaned the whole house and by the
way we were never allowed to have people
over because he never thought the house
was clean enough ever and so it bummed
me out cuz I had the only reason I liked
living on my own was because I wanted to
invite people over and I love hosting I
love meeting drinks for them and stuff
anyway I never allowed to have people
over and when did he clean the whole
house and I went to the kitchen and I
was [ __ ] starving because you know
you need food to live and I went to make
myself an avocado toast and I started
heating something you know how like when
bread gets toasted it begins a little
crumbly so he is hovering over me like
watching me make this [ __ ] avocado
toast and I'm like trying to be as
careful as possible because he explodes
if he just cleaned something and it gets
messy so I'm like being as careful as
[ __ ] possible I swear to god bro like
the tiniest crumbs okay just clean the
kitchen and I was like I'm sorry I don't
know what to do where do I go and then
wait to the living room he's like I just
like the living room and so I was a
[ __ ] eating avocado toast in the
bathroom that's he like would iron every
hit his jeans his t-shirts as do that
was nuts dude and then keep wonder why I
never wanted have sex with him yeah but
he looks like did he talk about it dirty
or was there any weird thing with such
yeah oh there's he's I've told some
stories about him he was the guy that
would suck my toes and he would like the
nerdiest party or like rub his he would
like rub his belly but he does dude yeah
towards the end of our relationship like
he just begged me to let him jack off
while I'm while I was sleeping so but
while he's looking at me and I was like
okay why would you even ask you for that
you're asleep you don't know because he
was trying to make something happen I
was like I'm tired he's like can I shut
off right here oh my god okay
it's like the one guy that I dated the
6th uber OCD clean it's really weird
because like he's very like crazy clean
about only certain things whereas the
rest kinda like whatever like like a
kitchen super clean
amazing bedroom super clean toilet gross
oh yeah the other way around it's just
disgusting like babe oh your piss all
over that [ __ ] yeah I guess [ __ ] and it
[ __ ] bounces back up and hits the
toilet they don't ever touch the toilet
why are guys like that exactly sort of
like everything else ever change sheets
oh when he was a bachelor and didn't
live with a girlfriend like had never
lived with a girlfriend ever changed his
bed sheets every like he never did
laundry he would just like he would just
kind of like put a comforter over if
someone came over he ever cleaned his
bed sheets feeling after things only
certain things they're not like full
crazy like Jane
this is certain things which is very odd
super super hygienic like heating
showers multiple times a day and like
he's very like very very clean as a
person like his person is clean but his
environment a filthy [ __ ] mess and
this is coming from a slob but I have
learned how to like at least keep an
environment really safely tidy or like
have a routine that yeah keeps it tidy
like once or twice a week
it's like shitty because like go on it's
so shitty because you look at your
environment you're like I ass is clean
tip them it's like this is not clean no
but it's clean I think Italy everywhere
I'm like man this could this could use a
cleaning like and literally everyone
like no matter who it is
like there's it's very rare where I go
places and I'm like oh wow this is
cleaner than my place what do you think
about tips place her new place or her
old place her old but I haven't been in
the new place well her old places was
usually she always picked up before we
came over I don't know how it is on a
regular basis I say I I would know like
like I knew she cleaned up before we
came
my version of cleaning up before people
come over is just like throwing
everything in a closet because I'm and
then all the surfaces are totally dirty
so like it's cat hair every yeah my
version is there's nothing on the floors
yeah yeah
and my Edie the maybe I'll wipe down the
drips on the mirrors like the yeah yeah
that's about it dude you guys I bend
over the sink and brush my teeth into
the sink so that there's no toothpaste
marks on like you gotta do things when
you're this OCD to like avoid the mess -
I tried it like doesn't work for me I
like can't eat a meal without spilling
on myself so I think there's something
wrong with you I'm like like my ex you
are I mean you guys literally every
shirt is stained yeah I hate I hate
cleaning like like the guys I date you
like so how do you get your place clean
like what the [ __ ] I hate cleaning but
the thing as I find solutions to my
problems no I mean mmm I hire someone to
clean for very good you know take care
of it in some way exactly I'm not the
one that's cleaning but I'll find a way
to find you know to find solutions to my
problems I just hired someone
another thing is since we both work from
home and live at home obviously since we
both got our own offices now because our
last apartment
Steve had to work in the living room so
literally whole house was always clean
are always dirty but now we both work in
our offices all day and so the living
room stays pretty clean and looks like
it looks like week passes like clean
people but yeah you go in our offices Oh
Rick yeah you know exactly the same I
love it so ridiculous do you find a way
to go around it yeah dude those liked it
like pass that was my bedroom in high
school like there is only a path from my
bed to the door and that's it but the
difference is like I'm never dirty like
there's not like mold and shitty growth
yeah it's just a clean se I just have
[ __ ] everywhere so it's
you're cleaning at some point you're not
cleaning often enough I'm not well it's
it's more like you know what is
unorganized is what it is yes there's a
better bet dirty chaos
exactly well like if you were to ask me
where is this I'll know where it is like
it's under the 16 piles of shoes over
there you know I can't like my anxiety
yeah yeah well it's not like I have I
leave trash and all that gross stuff
it's just that I have a lot of stuff
yeah yeah you need to start being a
minimalist I know I tried that so before
I moved to mate this place that I'm in
now I like I completely purged so much
stuff and now I was like two years later
I'm just like and it doesn't help but
you have like PR boxes and then just
keep it you're like oh let me use that
for later sometime that's when my dad is
always my dad is always told music you
know men don't ever want to marry messy
girls and I'm just like oh that's why
Mickey got married so yeah as long as
the man is just as messy as you or
messier yeah yeah yeah
but I used to say that I was mess
playing cuz my dad used to yell at me he
would scream at me because I was not I
could not [ __ ] clean up after myself
I just didn't see the mess so I was like
a mess blind because to me I look at a
table and I like looks pretty clean but
they had you do not see this [ __ ]
dish in the middle like a weird like
what is it that some people notice the
mess and some people really it just
glazes over standards you not I mean
like like for my dad he was like
militate like no dust like he if he wore
a white gloves and he ran his finger
over the ax but you won't see no dust
whatsoever whereas for like other people
she's like got a little bit dust is fine
you know she's different
yeah well now I mean I've gotten better
because that guy that I lived with
taught me to see a little bit of mess
because then it wasn't just my dad it
was like this guy that I had a romantic
relationship with so I wanted I wanted
to do better cuz we all sent ofthere but
now so now it's weird because I'll be on
the other side of the argument because
I'll see stuff that Steve leaves out but
and I see it and he does
see it and I'm like I know your point so
so well I don't know elective it's so
hard for me to get mad at you because
I'm that I'm also I spent so long
cleaning this to clean it up go your
toast in the bathroom you just like
knows it here it's just a bathroom so
weird thing she does I have a question
guys before we leave I want to get into
like do you think that ridiculous
arguments are a sign of a relationship
that doesn't work do you think they
completely are just a non-factor do you
like because there are some people there
like oh we never argue over anything
ever I think that's really no matic - I
don't trust people that is it we don't
argue like we still argue it just
doesn't get into like scream a as we
don't resent each other we don't think
of each other as the enemy I think it's
the way that you communicate through
those arguments that I always understand
that we're on the same team and I've
never had that in a relationship before
where when we get in an argument it's
not a war it's just like both of us
trying to find a resolution where we
understand each other but people that
don't argue at all I feel like one
person's got to be holding resentment or
something like they're bottling it in or
just like hold repressing so is it
possible for anyone out there like that
you're that you're actually having a
relationship that's real and good and
true and you never argue over stupid
[ __ ] do you think that's possible maybe
it's maybe even boring I think
relationships before where like we never
argued but at the end of the
relationship we just realize we're not
right for each other you know right but
every time I hear that it's like oh we
never argued but it didn't work out yeah
but it's also like at the end we just
have maybe you just have different goals
at the end towards you know like I
didn't see myself marrying him but like
throughout the whole relationship was
chill like we never argued because we
always certainly were so like in tune
with each other you know what I mean so
it was fine so it was just at the end
the big picture was we don't have the
same
that's it so and honestly most of them I
want to say 99.9% of my relationships as
I rarely ever argue because I'm not that
type you know and I mean and I've never
gotten into like the only person that it
got really ugly for was that guy that
dated briefly that tried it like that
threatened to hit me but other than that
it's just like hey I'm not happy about
this let's toss this out and I've never
gotten I don't really feel like a little
screaming match and like throwing things
like [ __ ] you or whatever I'm really big
on like never cussing him out you know
unless they really [ __ ] up like that
dude that 13 hate me rose and falls in
the wall like I put his manhood on the
table and everything you know but yeah
other than that like I don't really
argue I don't I don't I don't like
arguing so I just lay it out like you
need to talk to me about this as an
adult you know and there's people who
don't know how to do that like I I did
that one speaker that I was dating and
then he was more used to like no well
you're being blah blah I'm like don't
talk to me like that like we're gonna
discuss this like adults
you know and he wasn't really used to
that so I think there are relationships
where you don't argue but it still
doesn't work out in the end because of
other like you just fundamentally
different people and I also feel like
having small arguments and quips or I
mean like [ __ ] like that doesn't
necessarily mean your relationships I
can work out I there I mean look at
Nicky and Steve they're fighting over
[ __ ] lots and dance yeah I feel like
you guys get off a little bit on those
I'm very stimulated because he actually
likes debating which I hate I don't like
getting into an argument but if I
disagree with you and you won't see my
side then I'll stand my ground and argue
with you yeah
but it it shouldn't get into a screaming
match in whenever it has between Steve
and I like we've apologized immediately
like because we know neither of us ever
want it to go there you know times
there's some deep-seated issues that are
more psychological like personal
psychological issues that haven't been
dealt with individually and then it
comes into the relationship with a
trigger or something but I feel like
we're both aware enough to to know
whether it's like just a trigger from
something else or very actual thing to
do with the relationship
so I'm just being self as aware as you
can be as always really good I'm
actually really curious so how do you
guys and Steve also how do you guys
apologize oh I think because personally
I've never done that before I really
wanna learn yeah admitting the parts
where I could take responsibility for
like being like okay I see how this
would have hurt like I'm sorry I did
that I never then if the intention is
never to hurt the other person then
whether you meant to hurt them or not
but they got hurt I will apologize for
that because I didn't want you to be
hurt so I I'm sorry like I don't I
didn't mean to hurt you Yeah right
but if it's something where like they're
just being petty over something then
apology right because it's so funny
because like in Asian households I
noticed this in a lot of Asian guys at a
date they are not Asians in parents
whatever in general are not good at
apologies that's so true that's insanity
men are not good at apologies I will say
yeah they'll try to do something nice or
say something nice or whatever without
apologizing so they'll trialing brush it
it's almost like a sign and their way of
apologizing is hey do you want something
to eat or something or like yes so like
you look nice today I'm like I look nice
today awesome Misha without see we're
gonna brush this under the [ __ ]
carpet dude like I want to hear an
apology
ya know yeah dude my dad would never
apologize he would just make jokes if he
was wrong like he would like to scream
at me and then like later he'd realize
he was wrong and he'd be like why you
gotta make me mad all the time
[Applause]
[ __ ] like I kind of like though I know
I mean I got it like it's for some
reason
if a guy does that I'm kind of like I
kind of like it because you know you're
wrong
yeah but like you don't want to admit it
so it's kind of manly and it kind of
pisses me off a little bit but I kind of
respect it I don't know I kind of like
that yeah it would get cute
we didn't emotionally damaged me be very
cute Jess it's easy for me to think
about it but probably not in reality
there's this one year that I was dating
where like we got into an argument and
then I was so mad and we're saying you
know what fine with them we just don't
see eye to eye and I went to the bedroom
and I just fell asleep because that's
what I did that's my default like
cuddling me music I'm sorry and you had
some really good arguments and like I
was like kind of half asleep so I didn't
respond and then he goes okay I'm just
gonna go out I'm gonna go hang on the
living room then since you don't want me
here
you know and I knew that so I was just
like come here it's okay seriously I'm
very like um so I've learned to
apologize over the years like if any
part of the argue like I'm very open to
hearing like okay I did do that wrong
and even in here the moment when I'm
angry if I acknowledge that I'm wrong I
will apologize and my trip to apologize
is I'm sorry but I did that and it made
you feel that way and then I'll never
follow up with a but you know blah blah
blah
you know I never erases the apology
exactly so I'm making a point to
apologize without like giving like an
excuse afterwards yeah let me sincerely
own this that I [ __ ] a month yeah yeah
well man that hour flew by dude I feel
like I didn't even get to my psycho
story so just so you know I'm the
[ __ ] angel
toast in a bathroom okay I've never done
anything patty okay I've never been
wrong ever ever because I've never wrong
never had to prove it's [ __ ] yeah let
me know show me Oh all right guys we
love you thank you for listening also
shout out to our sponsors once again and
we'll have more girls back on the
rotation next week and we will until
then subscribe we miss you guys miss our
studio but yeah these boobs are nice bye
bye [ __ ]